whoo great hike today buddy now let's
come up that last hill
and i turned around and you were nowhere
to be found
i thought i was gonna have to go back
and get you ah at least we made it
oh yeah i forgot to tell you i uh i i
talk in my sleep oh yeah quite a bit
actually so um if it bothers you just uh
wake me up
okay buddy oh
night
night
[ __ ]
your stupid dick head
jordan let's go camping come on jordan
keep hiking we're almost there oh
buddy
so much [ __ ] energy
shove that cliff bar
up your ass you bald sucker
[Applause]
you
keegan
hyphen
michael
key jordan
wake up you're talking in your sleep not
asleep yet
oh nature's gonna be so great once we
get shelf nature up your ass you bald
sucker and by ball sucker i mean you
suck bald still awake
hey what's wrong man i was having a
nightmare
oh again
but you want to talk about it i miss
mommy
hey
i know i know it's hey me too me too pal
come here man
[Music]
it's all right hey it's okay it's gonna
be okay
[Music]
i just don't want anything ever happened
to you
happened to me hey come on man ain't
nothing ever gonna happen to me really
yeah
that's what i said
so yes that i'm nothing never gonna
happen to me you ain't never gonna have
to worry about nothing happen to me but
what if what if you got hit by a car or
something
that's
impossible because i will never die
so i can't
die no matter what you can't die
but i thought all human beings died
that's true that's true that's science
so that's true but i
am lucky cause i'm
i'm not a human you are not
i never told you about this no
you know i'll just let it out i'm from a
planet
called
thelonious the thing is it was being
destroyed all right
that's what happened my
was i was sent down here in in a capsule
to earth by my parents oh like superman
superman
yep
that is what it is exactly like
except oh here's the thing about my
version only one superpower immortality
oh
yeah so i'm tired daddy's tired
can you
let's go to sleep okay listen i'm not
gonna live forever right because
because i'm only half alien
oh no
so i'm gonna die
mm-hmm
you
you you write about yourself ex
but
here it is
this one slit my mind
you can build with me immortality the
machine
to give you what i got from the remnants
of my spacecraft so yeah wow you're
gonna be immortal
you gonna be immortal daddy when are we
gonna get the remnants
tomorrow tomorrow
gonna get them tomorrow during
work
hey you got anything that looks like
parts of a crash spaceship
dead mom mm-hmm
right this week
power of christ compels you
for his compassion
let me suck your
[Music]
could you please clear the room
[Music]
welcome to papa mattress liquidators how
can i help you today
i need to buy a new bed okay yeah good
good you came to the right place i'd be
more than happy to help you uh what size
you need a fool queen
king queen queen oh okay well we got a
big city
so you know
it needs to be sturdy all right
[ __ ] gets kind of crazy in my room
oh
okay
i got you brother
i got you
well it's a
posturepedic mattress we got right here
this is extremely comfortable and uh
durable
do you mind if i try it no not at all go
ahead
i should also mention there's a hundred
percent money back guarantee on yeah
yeah yeah who got that good d i got that
good d yeah
no it's too hard
do you have anything softer
um
of course
so
this uh this one of our um
natural latex mattresses
it's uh on sale two today at uh twelve
hundred dollars can i try it
sure
who got that good d i got that good d
who got that good d i got that good d
it seems a little pricey okay no it's a
little pricey i ain't gonna lie to you
but uh no problem we got other choices
uh
this is a great memory foam mattress
right here it's a little cheaper
and can i try it out
right
right yeah i mean of course you want to
try it
you know how it goes
yeah coming up on them late nights
yeah man um
sex happens
[Laughter]
oh here it comes here it goes
yup that's the one
i'll take it okay let me bring you up
[Music]
speaking hello riaz i would like to
report an item which i ordered that
arrived broken
wendell sanders mockingbird lane that's
right i am showing the last item that
you've received is the superman bed with
the mattress of solitude that's the one
ordered it from a son for his birthday
but i cannot give it to him like this
and i'm pretty darn tootin pissed about
it
sorry sir i will start processing your
reorder right now with you on the line
okay i ain't mad at you riaz it's just
the system i know okay thank you for
understanding that
kids eh
huh
oh
okay well yeah i just got the one myself
had sex with a woman and everything to
get him
how long is this going what is your
son's name
oh
um
[Music]
stimpy
pretty much stimpy i have boys too i'll
tell you sometimes they can be a real
couple of universes
so you're preaching to the choir
stimpy don't you
give me that look you're gonna get it
when your mama comes home oh man sounds
like your wife is [ __ ] on wheels you
got that straight riaz
hot little biscuit though name's claire
body10 face 10. so
pretty much hit that every night
sexually
anyway what's holding up oh one more
minute
and uh how old is her son
15.
15. and he still wants a superman bed
a late bloomer
enjoy it while you still can
he'll grow out of the toys any day now
they all do
and the second he starts hooking up with
the girls he'll forget all about that
superman and spiderman stuff
pretty much seems like how it would
happen
maybe then he'll stop bothering me with
all those stupid little facts about how
those characters you just named are
clearly from two distinct and separate
universes sadly some people never move
on sad i got a better word for you
pathetic well i i i wouldn't say but
that's okay hey i cause them likes i see
some reals and i don't tolerate nerds in
fact let me nip this in the bud real
quick stimp it stimpy get back in here
i didn't mean to there you are with your
brown body and your creepy ass face no
more sweets for you cause you're never
gonna get laid if you keep eating sweets
and another thing
all these
figurines and toys you got around the
house we're throwing them in the trash
cause they're not real people stimpy
they're not real people so stop being so
lonely stop being
so lovely
[Music]
well
and this is none of my business of
course
but i was wondering if your
son
would like to talk to someone
oh simply just jumped out the window oh
my gosh oh he killed himself why to do
it it must have been my fault no it
wasn't yes it was i'm gonna call the
cops don't you dare cancel that reorder
it's the only thing i'll have to
remember him bye
[Music]
go on yes
i'm here
promise you'll never forget about me
yes
of course
promise we will take care of our little
girl
love her
yes
[Music]
promise me you'll stay strong for her
yes
yes
i promise
and promise me you'll never sleep with
another woman
[Music]
i hear you
promise me you'll take care of mr big
fluffy tail yes
yes yes yes
that cat will be
the most loved cat in the world
and that you won't look at porn
no pornography buster brown
says what
is that a yes
yo
better believe i heard washington's hair
girl
you love me right yes i love you yes
and we're soul mates right yes
so you will never
ever ever think of someone else while
masturbating right
message received
i don't understand is that a yes
yes is that a promise
your request has been filed say you
promise
forget about
huh huh
i need to hear you say it i
say i pro i promise you promise you
you promise
say it
okay i promise no air quotes
promises are the things that love
say it
i promise i promise
what are you promising i promise what
you said oh fine forget it yes
i mean
okay
you at least promise to go see my mom
every day
so zero pornography done
i like that
nurse
fix my wife
[Laughter]
don't touch me right now
this is not all about you
[Music]